I'm gonna come clean with you guys I'm
sick of being laughed at even though I
didn't vote for the guy I'm sick of
being the laughingstock on this planet
the entire planet is laughing at us
making fun of us we are the punchline of
every global political joke because of
Donald Trump now his followers may not
know or they may not care Trump may keep
telling himself and us that we are the
envy of the world including on our
handling of coronavirus and testing and
everything else but it's not true and I
am really embarrassed by it because it's
shameful to be this laughingstock the
whole world thinks were a joke because
Trump is a joke and Appelbaum our rights
that in China the official Chinese news
agency is pushing videos making fun of
us
claims by Donald Trump that it's only a
flu claims that are embarrassing to go
back and look at today that video has
gone viral in Indonesia they wrote in
disbelief about Trump proposes
disinfectant injection and UV rays to
treat kovin 19 in France reports say the
rantings of dr. Trump ridiculing him
once again in South Africa an article
promotes the horrors of US President
Donald Trump leaving people stunned and
confused with his bizarre suggestion
that disinfectant and ultraviolet light
could be used to treat the virus in Peru
a newspaper article called attention to
dr. deborah birx 'as visibly pained
expression as trump wondered aloud about
bleach injections to treat corona virus
and meanwhile as the world laughs Trump
insists everybody looks up to us
everybody looks up to him on coronavirus
and testing and everything we're doing
here is Trump at a recent event making
this case and we're going to do a job
like like nobody's seen before and I
spoke with Angela Merkel today I spoke
with Prime Minister Abbey of Japan I
spoke with many of the leaders over the
last four or five days and so many of
them almost all of
I would say all of them not everybody
you'd want to admit it but they ovo us
as the world leader and they're
following us you look at what we've done
with ventilators we started this is one
of two things either a clueless person
saying something that they believed to
be true which is not which is obviously
not true or it's gaslighting it is
making someone believe is making someone
question the reality by telling them
something that is completely
disconnected from fact if any of them
are looking to us if other countries are
looking to the United States it's to
avoid doing what we did because almost
every country has handled coronavirus
better than we have Russia now is
becoming a mess it's a mess in Russia
and they're rapidly becoming one of the
epicenters Russia maybe handled this
worse than the United States we don't
know yet it's early Brazil is becoming a
major cesspool of coronavirus
transmission we know about dryer balls
on our O's skeptical attitude towards
the virus India is growing Lee growing a
problem not growing Lee is increasingly
a problem when it comes to the virus
we'll see if they are able to turn it
around but otherwise everybody would be
looking to us to not do what we've done
they're not impressed with us we're not
the leader here they're laughing at us
now there's a new report which says it's
actually worse than just laughter
laughter would be one thing there's a
new report that says the world is
actually despairing because countries
that have become used to seeing the us
at the table figuring out solutions now
we're seeing the u.s. as completely
useless because of Donald Trump European
critics say it's not just that Trump
isn't helping like the United States
normally does Trump is eroding respect
for the United States and getting in the
way of global cooperation and solutions
this has real-world implications and I
want to be clear about that this is not
a haha Trump segment our global position
is being destroyed by this man electing
Trump in 2016
instantly called into question the US as
being a serious country but maybe it was
a mistake
if Trump is Ari
elected it will cement the United States
as a joke and there's no other way to
say it
if that happens we are going to have to
face the reality that American voters
are as much of a problem as Trump
himself and the people Trump hires now
we've suspected this for a while we've
talked about it for a while but it will
be the the last confirmation if we
reelect Donald Trump we will know that
the disaster actually afflicts 60 maybe
even 70 million people who may vote for
Trump in November of 2020 the world is
laughing a lot of people actually take
pleasure in that Trump astaire about our
reputation around the world or they
simply tell themselves our reputation is
great but this is not good and it must
be stopped I want to give a quick shout
out to one of our sponsors VIN Charo
watches they're giving my audience 15%
off your entire order when you go to
david pakman.com slash watch maybe you
don't usually wear a watch and you've
been thinking about looking for one to
elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have check out VIN Charo it's an
American company all of their watches
are built in small batches from high-end
materials they look amazing and they
look like something you'd spend a lot of
money on but ever even Cheryl watch
ranges from a hundred and fifty to three
hundred dollars I went on their website
and picked out the Kyros in white and
silver really love the look the
combination of the white face and the
beige band really love this one they
also sent me the Kairos limited release
gold reserve set totally different style
this one would make a fantastic gift for
a couple people I can think of in my
family anytime you see me wearing a
watch on the show I'm wearing a Ventura
watch go through their collection I know
you'll find something you like and
you'll get 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch